the wife of an American diplomat now
formally charged in the death of a
British teenager is refusing to return
to Britain to face trial an cyclists
fled after she was accused of causing a
crash that killed 19 year-old motorist
Harry Dunne empty as tyub spoke with the
victim's family Harry Dunn's parents
shed tears of relief we feel that we've
taken a huge step in the start of
achieving the promise to Harry that we
mate
to bring and cyclists to justice British
authorities charged cyclists with Harry
Dunn's death she admits to hitting him
while driving on the wrong side of the
road outside this British military base
where her husband a US intelligence
official was stationed the 42 year old
American fled the UK just days after the
collision under diplomatic immunity
you've been fighting so long for this
news to get on sequoias charged how's it
feel huge relief and now that that first
huge hurdle has been cleared the second
is for the British government it now has
to ask for an Psicosis extradition from
the United States but her lawyers are
already saying there's no chance
whatsoever
she'll voluntarily turn herself in Jeff
heartbreaking case MTS thank you very
much
you